Video cameras were new
and we were v-very excited
about the technology.
You don't have to explain
yourself to nobody.
- Thank you.
- Alright, here it is.
[gunfire]
(Big Mike on TV)
Alright, on me.
I love you, Brenda.
One, two, three!
[gunfire]
[bleep]
Aah!
[screaming]
[gunfire]
Oh, my God! Aah!
Aah! Aah! Oh, my God!
Aah! Aah! Aah!
Wow.
[chuckles]
(Dangle)
'Never came to work again.'
- Never came to work again.
That was it.
What do you think, Jonesy?
- Not a bad look, huh?
- 'Kind of good.'
Kind of good, in fact.
'I don't remember this.'
Where's Trudy?
- Oh, no!
- Oh, my God, no!
Oh, god, no!
'Oh, my god, no!'
(Williams)
'Itching gas!'
Come on! Come on!
Get her out!
Oh, God, no! No!
No!
Goddamn it!
You live, woman.
Goddamn it.
You live, Trudy Wiegel!
Oh. Okay. Wait.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
You're fine.
You're okay.
She's alive.
- Mmm.
- She's alive.
Is this a surprise
party for me?
She was dead for 14 minutes.
Oh, that'll kill a brain
right there, yeah.
Shouldn't have revived her.
Nope. That's what
the doctor said.
The doctor said
should have let her go.
It's like if Marilyn Monroe
had woken up from those
sleeping pills and become
a dribbling, farting [bleep].
Why are they showing
this on TV right now?